so according to many different insiders
Marvel Studios is preparing to make some
really big really major announcements
really soon not just about particular
projects but about the MCU overall in
fact this year at sdcc many are
expecting a complete and entire Phase 6
reveal because remember we only have
three projects officially revealed from
Marvel Studios for Phase 6 so far and of
course with all these announcements are
going to come the announcements of the
official cast members for certain
projects including the Fantastic 4 and
other projects like NOA and I know a lot
of people are excited about these but I
think right now A lot of people are
really curious to hear what Marvel
studios's plans are for Kang since
Marvel is planning on doing such major
announcements soon are they going to
announce their plan for Kang the
Conqueror or could they perhaps be
announcing that there really aren't any
more plans for King the Conqueror in the
MCU and they're simply going to phase
him out out or could they simply
announce a recast of the character a lot
of things happening really really soon
so we're going to break down everything
that you need to know in this video and
we're going to start with Ryan Gosling
he's met with Marvel Studios and now we
know about the specific role that he has
met with Marvel Studios about but before
we continue be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest MCU
news and never miss a video we're also
doing a giveaway but we'll talk more
about that at the end so we've heard
Ryan Gosling's name mentioned a lot at
one point in time we heard that was
going to be Mr Fantastic at another
point in time we heard that Marvel
Studios was considering him to be the
Silver Surfer we've heard that Marvel
Studios wants him to be Nova and the
interesting thing is all of these at
some point in time could have been true
if you know how Marvel Studios work
specifically Kevin feige when it comes
to Casting certain people for certain
roles then you know that Kevin feige
meets with one actor well really a lot
of actors but specifically talking about
one actor he meets with them a lot about
many many different roles in fact Kiana
Reeves has been the subject of talk
recently because Kiana Reeves could have
been in the MCU at many different points
in time Kevin fige actually admitted on
the record that they talked to Kiana
Reeves pretty much for every project
they have coming up to see if there's a
role for him in that project now for our
sake and his sake I really hope it's a
movie and I really hope it's ghost riter
but there was talks about him playing
multiple characters in the MCU for a
while now in fact he could have played
Craven the Hunter and Spider-Man no way
home if that's the direction they chose
to take it in however since Andrew and
Toby jumped on board they decided not to
go with Craven also it sounds like Sony
really didn't want them to use Craven
before their Craven movie came out but
point being Kevin fige meets with one
particular actor about many many
different roles so when it comes to Ryan
goling at one point in time he might
have been up for the role of Mr
Fantastic of the Fantastic 4 he might
have been up for the Silver Surfer and
he might have been up for Nova all could
certainly be true however we have
recently heard from Insider Daniel rpk
that right now Marvel Studios
particularly wants Ryan Gosling to play
Nova in the MCU and they are in talks
right now about making this happen it's
also important to note that Ryan Goslin
is clearly interested otherwise they
wouldn't be in talks right now he would
have just brushed it off and said hey no
thanks I don't think that's the role for
me but since the report is specifically
Ryan Gosling has had talks with Marvel
Studios about playing Nova that means
both parties are interested both Ryan
and Marvel and if you think about it
both sides are probably really
interested in the other side Ryan
Gosling just played Ken in the Barbie
movie he was really big before he was
pretty much a superstar now he's a mega
star Marvel would be dumb not to want
him in the Marvel Cinematic Universe he
would definitely bring in some money he
would bring in some views and as far as
Marvel Studios goes I mean it's the MCU
we have Deadpool 3 coming out with Hugh
Jackman returning as Wolverine we have
Avengers Secret Wars Andrew Garfield
Toby Maguire had returned recently to
reprise their roles of Spider-Man and
despite what some people people might
think about how phase 4 and the
beginning of Phase 5 are the future of
Marvel Studios really is bright and
exciting so it would totally make sense
that Ryan Gosling would want to jump on
board as a major character of the MCU
which Nova is going to be in fact it's
believed that Nova is probably going to
go on to be the leader of the Guardians
of the Galaxy the new Guardians of the
Galaxy team and if that's what they're
pitching the Ryan goslan that's probably
really appealing since the first
Guardians of the Galaxy franchise was
one of the best there was out there from
Marvel Studios so Ryan Gosling right now
might be thinking he might be able to be
the next Star-Lord except it's his own
character Nova which fans have really
been waiting to see in the MCU for a
very long time so I think it would be a
win-win for Marvel Studios we'll have to
see if they negotiate everything and
make it happen but let me know what you
think about Ryan goling playing Nova
would you like that or would you not now
the Fantastic 4 is another story We Have
Heard many different reports about who
is going to be the official fantastic
forecast for a very long time that has
changed a lot as well and it could be
that Marvel Studios felt like they did
have it locked in but then something
happened and it didn't work out Adam
Driver was supposed to be our Mr
Fantastic for a pretty long time and
then it was revealed that he wasn't and
it looked like it was going to be padro
Pascal and it looks like that is indeed
who our Mr Fantastic is going to be now
as far as Vanessa Kirby is concerned we
haven't heard anything about that in a
really long time however today we do
have a new report about the Fantastic 4
coming from Daniel rpk as well and he
reported that the Fantastic forecast is
locked in and an announcement is
imminent now the good news about the
Fantastic for casting announcement is
that we probably won't have to wait till
sdcc or another con or something for
there to be an announcement about it and
that is because the Fantastic 4 is
supposed to begin filming relatively
soon we're unsure of the exact time
they're going to film but one report
said March another report said May
either way these are only months away
and if it's March that means are going
to be filming very very soon in which
Paparazzi who are going to be around the
set are probably going to start taking
pictures of the official cast which
means it'll leak out which means Marvel
Studios is going to want to beat them
beat the leaks to announcing the
official cast and this is why Daniel rpk
probably says that the casting
announcement is imminent because as soon
as they locked it in it's probably time
to prepare to announce to the world who
it's going to be and they know that
everybody's been waiting and keep in
mind Marvel Studios before has done
oneoff things where they make an
official announcement and they release a
specific slate of a certain phase or
they talk about specific actors joining
the MCU so keep in mind it doesn't even
have to be a con it doesn't have to be
sdcc it doesn't have to be an official
event they could put on an event of
their own online virtual like they've
done before and for something like the
Fantastic 4 something that Kevin fagy
deeply cares about I'm assuming we
probably will get a special event for it
maybe a YouTube video release online or
perhaps go live and reveal it that way
who knows but luckily for us it sounds
like that announcement will be soon the
last we heard Vanessa Kirby was going to
play SU storm AKA The Invisible Woman
and Eon Moss Bakr to play the thing in
which the other night he was asked an
impress interview about the rumors of
the Fantastic 4 if he could confirm or
deny his role in The Fantastic 4 and he
simply stated I can't confirm and I
can't deny so perhaps he could be
playing the thing and I think the last
we heard about the Human Torch is Joseph
Quinn from stranger things he was not
confirmed but that was one report that
he met with Marvel Studios to play the
Human Torch so we'll have to wait for
That official announcement but if this
is the cast in the meantime let me know
what you think about it do you like it
do you not what would you change what
would you keep the same let me know in
the comments down below and last but not
least the news about a possible Kang
recast or a new villain announcement
this will most likely come at San Diego
Comic-Con according to several different
insiders we should not not expect any
news really about the recasting of Kang
soon which means sdcc is probably when
Marvel Studios would choose to reveal
this so July is when we are most likely
going to get an announcement whether
Marvel Studios has decided to recast
King the Conqueror they will bring that
actor out on stage and simply say hey
this is our new king and you all know
why we have a new king or if they are
simply going to Pivot away from King
they will bring in the new actor playing
the new villain maybe Dr Doom maybe
somebody else and there they'll simply
say we're going to bring in a new big
bad of the MCU and then again probably
say you all know why now from what we've
heard Marvel Studios most likely isn't
going to get rid of Kang the Conqueror
they might push his character to the
sideline for a little bit but from what
insiders are saying it sounds like Kang
or a variant of Kang like the beyonder
variant of Kang is still going to be the
main big bad when we get to the end in
Avengers Secret Wars now who else could
they bring in in the meantime well it's
probably not going to be somebody super
super big like Doom unfortunately
because then Doom would only get about a
phase and a half as a big bad and I
don't think that's what we want I think
we would love for him to be built up in
a huge ginormous way and him to be
really involved in a lot of different
projects in the entirety of we'll call
it the Doom Saga I definitely think that
Doom should really get his entire Saga
and really be super involved in it with
the Fantastic 4 with the Avengers with
different Heroes and then become this
big bad that they all have to defeat he
is quite possibly the greatest super
villain in Marvel Comics history so he
deserves really the spotlight all on him
not to share it and I think Marvel
Studios probably thinks the same way but
luckily for us it does sound like Marvel
Studios is ready to make some big major
announcements pretty soon reveal the
rest of their plans for the rest of the
Saga and reveal phase six now I'm
assuming this is coming at sdcc but keep
an eye out because they may announce it
sometime before and of course if we hear
anything at all about it we'll be sure
to do an update video so be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest news be sure to let us know your
thoughts about all of this news in the
comments down below please don't forget
to like the video and if you subscribe
and leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win a PS5 an Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items the
winner picks one item and we pick one
winner at the end of every month you can
find us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof